hands up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome back to episode 119 of game
programming last time we took a look at
the UI button and creating this basic
button class and all we really had was a
way to display graphics today we're
going to actually make the button
functional okay so we're going to use
this UI button listener interface that
we've created but we didn't really do
anything with it we're going to use that
to actually listen for events okay
in our button and of course we're going
to raise them here in the update method
in the class so what's going to happen
is if we go into this button listener
for a minute here so that we can kind of
sketch out our idea for buttons and what
really should happen with them there are
probably a lot of events that we
actually want to listen for okay now
what am I talking about when I'm talking
about events and all these like things
that we're listening for what does that
mean well it's pretty simple in fact I'm
going to go ahead and do a bit of improv
here and because I wasn't planning on
doing this but you know what it's a good
idea and I always do this game
programming things live so let's just
see where this goes I want to draw you
guys a diagram so what happens is we've
got our game right this is our game we
just know it was black that is a normal
black anyway this is our game window
right so we've got this panel and we've
got like a button over here what happens
is when things occur with this button
what we want to do is certain actions
right now it's not just whether or not
we click on the button right so when
something happens with the button
whether it be a click or something like
that we want to process something yeah
we want to perform a certain action so
for example if someone clicks on the
button we might want to display the
options menu okay I don't know I'm just
creating I'm making stuff up maybe
there'll be a like a little exit button
on the bottom I don't know right it's up
to you guys and it's up to obviously the
game and whatnot but what we want to be
able to do is handle these events in an
elegant way so what we don't want to do
is have to like create a separate button
class for each type of button based on
its activity we don't want to do that
what we want to do is we want to have
our UI button
right which is basically our Universal
kind of class that will handle
everything right and all that we should
be able to do is set these actions up
for that so what are the actions that we
need right
what possible actions could our button
really use now there are three ones that
are really important okay they come to
mind straightaway okay one is clicking
okay if we click on the button we should
be able to do something that's pretty
simple right now there are I said two
more so I said three total but that
probably would be about four more that
we will probably implement there's the
click okay which I'll talk about because
that'll actually divide into two so
let's actually cover that right now this
will divide into two we've got the mouse
down okay and excuse my handwriting
because this graphics tablet is from
like - I don't know more than ten years
ago probably and it's just not very big
or comfortable to write on
but mouse down a mouse up right so when
we when we put the mouse down that
should be some kind of event and when we
actually kind of end our clique by
releasing the mouse we also want to
handle that event and I'll explain why
and give you some examples in a minute
so that's the click but there's there's
excuse me there are two more events that
aren't related to clicking that are
important okay and that's the mouse
entered okay and then the opposite of
that so mouse removed or something I
don't know mouse exited I guess yeah
mouse entered and mouse exited so
whether or not from the button the mouse
actually goes into the button or leaves
the button now why would we want these
things why not just have click right
well the reason we want these things is
because first of all buttons aren't just
interactable by clicking on them okay
that is the main form of interaction but
usually if you notice even even looking
at this UI when I put my when I put my
mouse on it if you look kind of in the
bottom left corner you can see that it
changes color right it goes a bit liars
you not to know that that's an it that's
like a clickable region it's not just
some kind of display then when I click
on it
you can see that it's actually a
different color here as well right so
what we kind of want to do is for
example when the mouse enters we might
want to change the color right so change
color okay when we put the mouse down we
might also want to change color and
maybe when we raise the mouse we want to
actually perform an event and then when
the mouse exits exits we also want to
probably change the color back to
whatever it was before okay so we've got
this whole like system that we need to
set up which might be unique for each
Mouse now we could be pretty like
controlling right we could be pretty
limited in the way that we design this
we could say hey man all you're allowed
to do is this click yeah you can
customize that I'll take care of the
rest of the colors and events okay so
what we could do is we could say that
you know what our button class we can
make it so that it changes color so you
might be able to set a foreground color
a:hover cover
I'm sorry a:hover color and they click
like a depressed kind of color which is
when we actually put the mouse down but
not lift it up right we could choose
that stuff and we could just kind of do
that and then it'll handle the amounts
separately but what I'm going to do
instead is if some excuse me I've got a
cold
if someone sorry is make them somewhat
customizable right so that we can
actually set them to whatever we like so
to do that we need to basically grab
these events and implement them into our
interface so what's going to happen is
every one rows the mouse right the mouse
class but everyone knows the mouse I
mean it's a static class so everyone has
access to the class so we don't want we
don't worry about this but you can say
even Mouse listener has and I've yeah
this is a new thing so let's go into
this is a fresh install so I'm using
Windows 10 is you probably tell um java
where's that out so let's attach the
source real quick so you can see that
how they've done it right and then
they've got the mouse event which is
kind of the conditions on which that's
happened
so when a mouse is pressed for example
Mouse event will contain information
such as the position of the mouse and
what buttons been press and all that
stuff right we don't really need that
but what we do need is to basically have
these conditions right so I am going to
say we've got to think up of names well
think up some cool names here as well so
public void I'm just going to come in
Java mouse entered what did let's
quickly go back here what do we have
mouthing ethics it release press clicked
yeah so entered exited pressed released
and we might have a action as well
now here's what here's what the deal is
I don't actually want to do it as an
interface the reason is I want to give
it some defaults I believe Java now has
a way to set defaults if you go like
default void I don't know does that work
no yes so you can do something about if
you were a 1.8 I'm kind of excuse me I'm
kind of not going to do that just to
keep compatibility but yes you can do
stuff like this as well but what we're
going to do instead and there are
benefits to that for example you can
extend as many interfaces as you want
but only one class but it's alright
we'll just change us to be abstract
class instead of an interface because I
do want to predefined some behavior okay
I don't want it to all be completely not
defined so the only one that we really
need I'm going to leave is action okay
everything else is going to be I was
already going to have an implementation
that we don't need to necessarily
override okay this will just make it
easier to change things like colors okay
so what we'll do is
so we've got that good where's our
button what am I looking for UI button
when that go here it is so we've got
this class here so by default if you
don't specify anything that's gonna be a
bit weird as well you probably do have
to specify a button listener mmm I'm
just thinking maybe I should divided
into two from going that way so we might
have a bunch of just this and then also
an action that we have to do and then
maybe default set if yeah that could be
a bit better
okay so we'll have UI button listener
which is just an abstract class and then
we'll have another Volturi will have an
interface that it's going to be a UI UI
action listener so this isn't going to
be just for buttons okay well I don't
know what we'll just call this maybe
action maybe for form so perform will
actually perform the action so we've got
a UI button listener which we don't
necessarily need to do anything with and
then we've got because that'll exist by
itself as in it'll have default
functionalities what I mean so we'll
also have a UI action listener
okay so you should be able you should
have to specify a actionlistener and of
course when certain things will happen
we'll perform the action with you I
bottomless neither that's going to
basically be specified yeah so we could
do an anonymous inner type here where we
created I'm just wondering if there
might be a better way possibly if we
create a default class or something yeah
it just might be a bit messy to
everything here so what I'll do instead
is actually just say this this is just a
playing the card up so we could have
done an inline and one on but I'm just
going to create a class here so we'll
have a private class UI default button
listener which of course will stand UI
listener
and if we do that because I could have
done it here these will actually need
the button thing I'm actually going to
go back to having this as an interface
instead of an abstract class for oh you
know what I don't know why I'm doing
this because I could do instead sorry
I'm going back and forth but this stuff
is live and this is just me working so
what we do is we actually do set this as
a new UI button listener okay we go to
that class we get rid of abstract
because it does need to be abstract
anymore all right
done oops let's not play around too much
with Windows 10 so this is done now okay
so we've got these and this will be this
will be the default implement a
right so when we over here we can just
quickly add an action so we'll add a new
action listener here and we'll do
something like just I'm gonna add a
print line button pressed obviously we
also want to make sure that we don't do
we only press it once so that's the
different as well don't know how we'll
do that but we'll figure something out
of course you can go to that private
class and we're all good so what has to
happen is pretty simple
don't worry about button listen too much
that doesn't actually have any
functionality update is very important
though that will keep track of things so
we need to figure out where the mouse is
on the screen and how it is in relation
to us so this is a bit difficult because
of the fact that we've got so many
different offsets to account for so we
need to get we need to have luckily I
believe the position plus the offset
what we do need to do absolutely is
basically go into we're going to set
this up a bit differently because I feel
like that we need to kind of make it
better
so in a UI component and this is going
to be a bit of a long episode I'm afraid
I'll think you guys think that's a bad
thing obviously but I'm going to make a
public void get absolute position and
that's obviously not going to be void so
this will return this will return
position don't add offset okay
Java has a rectangle class
which could be used to speed things up a
lot because the rectangle glass has
something like inside contains okay and
we can figure out basically whether the
kernel rectangle contains a different
point so if you look at the
implementation for that it's basically
this so we can kind of steal that or
this is this is actually slightly
optimized so it looks a bit weird but
that's one thing that we can do okay
because that's basically what we're
doing I just think that might be better
than constructing a rectangle although
that doesn't seem too difficult so we
might actually just do that instead yeah
let's just do that and said so rectangle
rect equals so this is going to be the
button bounds basically we could even
store it like that since something that
has a size we should probably have our
own rectangle class to be honest but
whatever rectangle 2d what is it is it
actually rectangle
yes rectangle equals new rectangle we'll
just say forget absolute position dot X
well yeah okay whatever it's Java
hopefully it all ties this within
Heights sized on exercised or Y ok
rectangle and then all we have to do is
say if now starts sorry if rect dot
contains new points yeah we'll make our
own maths later I think because just
because this doesn't work without back
to system and I should so instead of
doing dot X dot Y if we don't need to do
that so we'll see it'll contain a new
point which is Mouse dog an X and Mouse
don't get why okay cool so if that is
the case we're basically inside so let's
just I don't even know if this will work
so let's just check this out there's
Wi-Fi button on rendering okay also it
doesn't work but why that button on
rendering that's but weird I didn't
change anything did I
um no I don't think so
that color yeah let's set the call it's
pink
real quick hmm that's weird
no rendering anymore that's very weird
did I do something bad
what'd I do so I added that hmm
interesting interesting so psychologist
calls yeah okay and we add that so that
doesn't matter all right think I didn't
do anything to me no no that's all good
so what's up man let's double check
what's going on so position dot X what's
the position at 10 and 260 plus the
offsets which is just zero Y is f of
zero that sounds a bit wrong
what's the offset always 9l so hang on
positions 216
yes wrong man why is the offset zero
that mean it was good we'll be getting
right into here but it is just not
getting rounded anywhere so that's even
weirder label seems fine hmm very weird
what else are we rendering we're
rendering a progress bar all right let's
check this out what's the offset for
this puppy zero as well maybe I'm wrong
why is he upset zero though that can't
be right
why is the author Sarah maybe it's just
for the first frame or something yeah
it's the restroom that's weird and
probably shouldn't make it do that
she'll probably should make it render
with an incorrect offset but that's
another one for the bug collection let's
just see what the officer actually is
then I'll skip a few frames
two frames offset is 660 and zero 360
plus whoa
what's up with that x-man does the
position change what hang on a minute
what Wow
you guys probably saw this in more like
lull okay there we go so hmm
now that web covering from that we can
set the color excuse me
back to this okay cool so if we're
inside as you can see it will say that
we're inside see nice and nice and
brilliant so to reflect this a bit
better what we could do is now that we
have that we could do something like
color a set color to water no man like
how about just a lighter version of that
will kind of keep it at be realistic so
maybe like CD that just looks like debug
memory to me all right
so you can see that it goes bright and
the purpose of this will just say else I
shall let those braces gonna name them
later we'll just say likes else set
color back to what it was before which
is that well I just do man that's we had
gotten to Mouse class somehow
so for that buttons man very cool so the
idea with that though is as you can see
we're doing some pretty cool stuff by by
just simply setting up the colors a bit
differently raaah sorry we're by simply
detecting whether or not we're in the
bounds right so what if we did something
like this right what if this is the code
that we've got what if we went into our
UI button listener and then said
something like well you know what let's
on enter to set the cards at all right
and then on exited set the color to that
what if we do some like that and then
simply called button listener dot
entered this and button lets know dot
exited this what if we did something
like that oh look it works fantastic
brilliant so this is actually the plan
okay we want to do something like this
now what we do want to actually do is
something a little bit different because
right now is going to be calling that
and both the entered and the exit event
a million times per second
okay sorry what I mean by that is it's
going to keep calling it right whereas
it's only aren't only really supposed to
call it once because we're not asking
whether it's inside or outside we're
asking whether it's in like whether it
has entered or exited that happens once
yeah so to reset this we need to control
it a bit a bit better right what we need
is a boolean so this boolean will be
something like inside so we're not we're
just going to assume the mouse is not
inside the button if the rectangle
contains the point then we'll set inside
truth clearly yeah before we do that we
need to say if inside is false we need
to run that code and then we set it to
true so next time it'll be false and
then over here we do the exact same
thing
we do if if it is inside then we call
exited it's currently inside and we've
the rectangle doesn't pretend anymore we
exit and then we set inside equal to
false okay this way it will only call it
once okay it still works as it does
before the only problem is if we alt tab
for example and go back okay that
actually worked well I'm a magician what
can I say but just to show you guys the
actual difference because obviously that
was one I mean I'm sure you guys
actually know but if we just did entered
and exited just like that so and then we
went here and we undid all of our hard
work here we set it back to what it was
before which was this obviously you can
see that we're permanently exited
entered and it's calling that code all
the time we don't want to do that
instead we go to the new system which is
this and if we do that you can see that
it only calls at once when we answer and
when we exit see so it works the same
way it's just much much better okay cool
so that is going to pretty much wrap up
this episode because we're already at 24
minutes but next time we're going to
talk about we will think about the press
and release stuff and really the action
so clicking on the buttons right so
we'll cover that stuff next time hope
you guys enjoyed if you did please hit
like button and I'll see you next time
goodbye
you